>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Carla Hayden: I'm Carla
Hayden, Librarian of Congress.
[ Applause ]
And this has been my first national
book festival as the Librarian
of Congress and what
a day it has been.
I have learned so much about the
outstanding writers who participated
in this event and I
will never forget all
of the book lovers I have seen
from all ages, all backgrounds,
and I just came back from the
poetry slam and I have to tell you
if you want to see raw
talent and emotion,
next year you have to be there.
It was wonderful.
And I'm especially pleased to
be able to present to you one
of the greatest authors that I've
met because he is the Library
of Congress' National Ambassador
for Young People's
Literature, Gene Luen Yang.
[ Applause ]
And I'm going to congratulate
him once again
for being named a MacArthur Genius.
[ Applause ]
Gene is the fifth National
Ambassador
for Young People's Literature
and the first graphic artist
to hold this position.
And before we get to his program,
I just want to make a
special announcement.
Mark your calendars
for September 2, 2017.
That will be the date of
the next book festival,
right here at the Washington
Convention Center.
So, I hope you can attend.
Back to Gene and enjoy and
thank you all for being here.
[ Applause ]
>> Michael Cavna: All right.
Hi. How do you follow that?
How do you follow a historic
new leader of this institution
between her and a brand new genius?
It's just, you know,
we'll do what we can.
But, my name is Michael
Cavna, a columnist cartoonist
with the Washington Post.
I do the Comic Riffs blog and I also
did the syndicated strip Warp you
can find at gocomics.com.
I've spent a lifetime in comics
and a lifetime as an art senator
and believe that graphic novels
are one of the most important
and crucial forms of communication
for young readers,
for reluctant readers.
I come from a tribe of educators.
We have an educator here.
Educators are my people.
So, three years ago,
when my daughter was
in a nearby school
and she had read Maus.
And she comes home, she's
sad, she's almost crying.
I said what's wrong.
She said my teacher said
graphic novels aren't books.
Can imagine my response to that, so
I went and marched to the principal
and the principal said, oh, yeah,
graphic novels aren't books.
So, I spent the next year
proving, in the Post,
that graphic novels are books.
And one of the first people I went
to, I thought who is an educator,
who understands librarians, and who
is a great graphic novelist himself?
And who just happened to be coming
through town but Mr. Gene Luen Yang
and we walked around the Post and we
shot a little video and at the end
of the year we had an
award-winning serious that proved--
the judges said once and for
all graphic novels are books.
So, that educator isn't very far
north of here, so do you mind just
as a favor to me one time saying,
for me, graphic novels are books.
On three. One, two, three.
Graphic novels are books.
Thank you.
I needed that.
And we have an institution
here wise enough to know that.
It is my true pleasure to have
Gene Luen Yang as our headliner,
finishing off this night.
It was January when we were not far
from here in the Library of Congress
and Gene was being inaugurated
as the National Ambassador
for Young People's Literature and
they couldn't have chosen better.
He began drawing comic
books in the fifth grade.
In '97, he received a Xeric Grant
for his first comic, Gordon Yamamoto
and the King of the Geeks.
Here is a man who proudly
calls himself a geek.
He has written things
like Duncan's Kingdom,
the Rosemary Comic
Book, Animal Crackers.
It was a decade ago,
American Born Chinese,
a brilliant cross-culture book.
Yes. Brilliant.
So many beautiful metaphors
all threading through.
Became the first graphic novel to
be a National Book Award finalist.
He followed that up with such
projects as Boxers and Saints,
which also was a National
Book Award finalist.
So, I think you're due pretty soon
for a third one in about a year.
He is just-- he did a brilliant
book about the Shadow Hero.
You should definitely
check that out.
He won an Eisner for
the Eternal Smile
and now he's doing this
wonderful-- he's, again, sneaking--
now he's sneaking education
into the graphic novels
with this series Secret Coders.
It's part comic, but you read
it and realize he's getting kids
to do problems, to solve, to think,
and that's part of his genius.
He taught high school for
nearly two decades in Oakland.
He's working on a long project,
Dragon Hoops about that teams--
that basketball team,
a diverse team.
He just does it all.
He even-- on top of Avatar: The
Last Airbender, on the side,
writing Superman-- just to
kind of through that in.
A think that's a lifelong
dream for many people,
he's just throwing that in there.
So, he's doing it all.
He just-- he's-- I've
had the pleasure
of moderating him numerous times.
He's just a fantastic
talent, a fantastic voice,
and a fantastic ambassador, I
believe globally, for comics.
Please welcome Gene Luen Yang.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Michael Cavna: So--
and-- all right.
Well, thank you for coming here.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah,
thank you for having me.
Thank you all for being here,
especially at the very end.
Thank you so much.
And thank you to Michael.
I don't know if you all know this,
but Michael is kind of like a ninja.
You know? He's at the post, he
dresses up as newspaper man,
but really he's a comics guy.
>> Michael Cavna: I am a geek who
likes to play with sharp things.
That's why I'm a ninja.
And thank you.
I mean, you know, I
was texting Gene-- I--
a little bird told me that
Gene would be getting--
just heard a little bit in
advance, a Genius Grant.
And so I'm like when can I
text him, when can I text him.
And here's someone you
can text, like, you know,
in the middle of the night and for--
in the name of comics,
he will respond.
He will be there.
He's a voice.
You know? So, it's fantastic.
Is the word-- I want to start,
is the word genius--
are you tired of it yet?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Well, I want to
hear it out of the mouth of my wife.
That's my goal.
>> Michael Cavna: I met your wife.
It's not going to happen.
She-- because she's too smart
to fall for that, right?
But-- and your kids right?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Oh, yeah.
Yeah. Anybody you see on a
daily basis is hard to impress.
>> Michael Cavna: And,
well, and I don't know
about you praising your
family because that came
with a $625,000 no
strings attached grant.
The one string is just to
support people who support comics.
You know? But, you know,
I wanted to ask you--
so, in January, you were
inaugurated as the ambassador.
You're used to-- you spent
your career in schools.
Now you get to go to schools.
You get to spread the Gospel
while you're still creating.
How are you finding it?
You know, it's a little bit
like winning an intellectual Miss
Universe where you have to show
up at so many functions, wear
the sash, but in the name
of graphic novels, in the names
of young people's literature
in many forms, but now
that you've been doing it
for almost 10 months, how's it been?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Well,
first, that's my second goal.
I want my wife to call
me Mr. Universe.
That would be awesome.
But it's been great.
>> Michael Cavna: For 625,000
you might be able to-- yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: It's been great.
It's been a little bit hectic.
I think this is one of the most
hectic years I have ever lived,
but it's also been awesome.
I love going to schools
and talking to kids about--
not just comics, but
books and reading.
And about how sometimes we put up
these artificial walls, right--
>> Michael Cavna: I was going to
say, can you talk about you theme?
Your message?
>> Gene Luen Yang: So, every
ambassador picks a platform,
the platform I chose is
reading without walls and by
that I just mean I want kids to
explore the world through books
and I want them to do it
in three specific ways.
Number one is I want them to choose
books about people who don't look
like them or live like them.
Two is I want them to
choose books about topics
that they might find intimidating.
And, three, I want them
to choose books in formats
that they might not
normally read for fun.
So, if you're a kid that
normally only reads chapter books,
I want you to try a graphic
novel or a book in verse.
And if you only read graphic novels,
I want you to try a chapter
book, any sort of other thing.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
So, did you practice
what you preach as a kid?
You were doing comics,
but, you know, you,
you know, you're brilliant.
You know, your knowledge in
computer programming is brilliant,
but were you reading everything?
Were you sort of open?
Did comics help you
break down other walls?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Well, one of
the reasons I wanted to do reading
without walls is because
it's something
that I would tell myself
to do when I was a kid.
I do remember-- I went
to the library a lot,
mostly because my mom took us.
Took me and my brother.
It was sort of a free
babysitter, I think.
>> Michael Cavna: Was
this in the Bay Area?
>> Gene Luen Yang: It
was in the Bay Area.
>> Michael Cavna: I-- literally,
my mom at the same time
taking us to the library.
We might have been at the same
library in the same comic aisle.
OK. Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Well,
that's the thing is that with--
I remember at my local
library we didn't really have
that great of a YA section.
It kind of went from J to adult
and there was nothing in-between.
I remember getting to like fourth,
fifth, sixth grade and starting
to feel a little bit lost
at the library and that's
when I discovered comics.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
And they filled something for you.
Filled that gap.
Yeah. What was your
first comic that you--
>> Gene Luen Yang: The very first
comic I got was a DC Comics Presents
number 57 staring Superman
and the Atomic Knights.
>> Michael Cavna: Wow.
And here you are writing
Superman now.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah,
it's kind of crazy.
It's a really crazy thing.
>> Michael Cavna: Do you
ever pinch yourself and--
>> Gene Luen Yang: Absolutely.
Yeah. I think-- it's unbelievable.
It's unbelievable.
I think if I had-- if
I could go back in time
and tell my 10-year-old self that I
would be doing what I'm doing today,
he would have just peed
himself and melted.
I mean-- ridiculous.
>> Michael Cavna: I'm going to
move on from that image, but, no,
but you were more of a Marvel guy.
DC was your first, but not
your first love necessarily.
>> Gene Luen Yang: No, no.
I actually-- I mean my mom
bought me that Superman comic.
I actually didn't want it.
The one I had wanted was a Marvel
two-in-one staring the Thing
and Rom the Spaceknight.
>> Michael Cavna: Oh, wow.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Both of whom were
like way cooler than
Superman, right?
Superman is such a square.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, but that's
what your mom would buy you.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Exactly.
>> Michael Cavna: Your mom
buys you Superman, right?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yes.
Yeah. But then that Superman
comic was mind-blowing.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, that was it.
And so but Marvel-- I
mean Marvel is known for,
for those that don't know,
is flawed characters,
often family dysfunction,
youthful dysfunction.
A lot of uncertainty.
Instead of the big blue boy scout.
It speaks to kids because of that,
which so much good
literature does, right?
It speaks to you in areas that
maybe you feel different or unusual.
So, did Marvel do that for you?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah, I
definitely was more of a Marvel guy.
I did read some DC.
I-- when I was a kid, Justice League
is not what we think of today.
It was not Superman,
Batman, Wonder Woman.
It was actually a bunch of DC
Comic's C- and D-list characters
and they sort of operated in
this weird sitcom environment
where they were constantly
making fun of each other.
That was the one book that I loved.
I loved that DC book.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
Absolutely.
Well, it was two years ago here
at the National Book Festival,
on Friday night there's a
gala nearby and Gene was one
of the speakers and he spoke
about comics and he spoke
about giving yourself permission--
any author, any writer--
to write cross-culturally,
but due diligence.
Do the homework.
And you talked about
Dwayne McDuffie,
the late Dwayne McDuffie
died at just 49--
fantastic writer, comics
writer, animator.
And you talked about as a young
African-American boy he was turned
on by Black Panther, again Marvel,
which was written by
two Jewish creators.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
Created by two Jewish guys.
>> Michael Cavna: And
they didn't, you know,
you said it was so--
they were so unsubtle.
They said we have to-- you
can't just name him the panther,
we have to call him
Black Panther, right?
We have to label it and yet to a boy
like Mr. McDuffie, it spoke to him
and so you spoke-- he gave one
of the most rousing speeches
they've ever had there
on why we need diverse books.
You can go online, you can
certainly find it at Washington Post
if you do Gene Luen Yang,
National Book Festival,
diversity, you'll find it.
It's worth reading.
You-- that was a powerful talk.
Can you talk about some of your
passion that went into that talk?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Sure.
I mean I think growing
up in America,
growing up with American stories,
it was very difficult for me
to find characters that look like me
in the stories that I was watching
and in the stories
that I was reading.
And I think, you know, there's a
professor by the name of Rudy Bishop
who talks about how literature
serves as both windows
into other people's lives
and mirrors into our own
and how kids really need to grow
up with those windows and mirrors.
And I felt like I had
a ton of windows;
I didn't really have any mirrors.
So, when I encountered Dwayne
McDuffie's work, you know,
he used to write an online column
and he talked about his love
of Black Panther, who is really this
flawed character, at least in terms
of representation, but he
talked about how Black Panther--
reading a Black Panther comic made
him feel like African-Americans,
black people, black
people were inevitable.
They became inevitable.
They were no longer
incidental to the story.
And when I read that column, I
though he is talking about something
that I myself had experienced.
The talk that I gave at the
gala really came out of my--
it really came out of my experience
as a teacher at Hamline University.
I teach creative writing
through a university in Minnesota
and one summer-- the summer
right before that gala, actually,
we started talking a
lot about diversity.
And it was part of a
larger conversation
that all books are having.
All storytelling.
We're having it in
terms of our movies,
our television series,
and our books.
And, you know, a lot of
my students expressed fear
about writing diverse characters.
They were worried about getting
it wrong and what my response
to that is-- well, in some
ways, that's kind of good.
It's good that you're scared that
you're going to get it wrong,
but what you should do with that
fear is not necessarily shy away
from the story you wanted to tell,
that fear should really just
drive you to do your homework.
It should drive you
to do your research.
I really do think, though,
that the diversity question--
it's two different questions.
There is the question for the writer
and then there is the
question for the gatekeeper.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Right?
>> Michael Cavna: There
is the page and the pen.
>> Gene Luen Yang Yeah, absolutely.
>> Michael Cavna: What we're
seeing on the page is the mirror
and then what we can't see, who is
getting an opportunity to create.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yes.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Exactly.
So, I do think from the
writer's perspective, you know,
I know from being a writer myself,
you are constantly
dealing with fear.
You are constantly dealing
with mental obstacles and,
as a teacher of writers, I am really
reluctant to add any more obstacles
into writers' minds, right?
But then, from a larger
perspective, from the perspective
of a gate keeper, when you look out
there and you say, you know, for--
let's say for Asian-Americans.
Let's say, you know, 80%--
if you find 80% of stories about
Asian-Americans are not written
by Asian-American authors,
there's something kind
of funky about that, right?
And it's not the responsibility
of the writer to deal with that.
The writer is just dealing
with his or her own fear.
>> Michael Cavna: Absolutely.
>> Gene Luen Yang: That's the--
that's the responsibility
of the gate keeper.
>> Michael Cavna: Absolutely.
Yeah. It's so, so true.
Now, how did you find early
on, you're pursuing comics
and things are opening up,
did you find it difficult?
Were you running into walls?
Were you running into windows?
Can you talk about
sort of your early ears
as a creator, as a writer?
>> Gene Luen Yang: I came up
through comics in the 90s.
In the 90s, nobody knew
what a graphic novel was.
That was not a popular term.
In the 90s, Marvel Comics
had declared bankruptcy
and people were expecting it
to just blink out of existence.
In the 90s, you could go
to Comic-Con in San Diego
and you could get tickets same day.
On Sunday, there were more
exhibitors on the floor
than there were attendees.
It was a really bleak time
to be in comics, right?
>> Michael Cavna: Except
for the lines.
Shorter lines, but
everything else was bleak.
You've already talked about
it; it's a revolution.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
Yeah, it really is.
So, when you're-- when you're--
like there are no gatekeepers when
there's no money around, right?
>> Michael Cavna: They
disappear mysteriously.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah,
they mysteriously disappear.
So, the bad thing about
that is that, you know,
when I came up in comics through
the 90s, I was not expecting
to ever be able to make
a full-time living--
I was never expecting to be able
to make money at it period, right?
But the benefit of that
is that I just felt
like I could tell whatever
story I wanted
and no one was going to tell me no.
Mostly because only 16
people were reading it, but--
>> Michael Cavna: And
so you pursued--
you became an educator and you've
worked with high school students,
you recently-- is it Bishop O'Dowd?
>> Gene Luen Yang: That's right.
Yeah. I taught at Bishop
O'Dowd high school in Oakland,
California for 17 years
and that was not--
that was more than
just a day job for me.
That was not something that I
was doing while I was trying
to make comics.
>> Michael Cavna: Oh, yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: It was because--
I mean, I genuinely like teaching.
Teaching's kind of awesome.
>> Michael Cavna: Oh, yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: It's a
really awesome profession.
>> Michael Cavna: And so
you taught computer science.
>> Gene Luen Yang: I did.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
So, how did you balance
that with creating comics?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Well, for years,
the way I would live is I would wake
up a little bit early, I'd work on
some comics before I went to work.
I'd go to work and then when
I got home, after dinner,
I would work on comics again.
I just didn't watch a ton of TV.
Stopped talking to like
half of my friends.
You know?
>> Michael Cavna: Now,
here's the question.
Did you tell your students
that you were doing this
or did you maintain being a comics
creator for as long as you could
as like a secret identity,
if you will?
>> Gene Luen Yang: At the
beginning, I totally told them.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: I remember
my first two years of teaching,
the very first day of every semester
I'd be like I am also a cartoonist.
Because I thought would be--
yeah, I thought they would think I
was cool, but they totally didn't.
No, it didn't work at all.
No, no. They thought it was-- they
thought it was a dorky, dorky thing.
And even worse than that
is when things got hard
in my class they would ask me
comic book-related questions
to get me sidetracked.
Yeah.
>> Michael Cavna: And
would you get sidetracked?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Oh, yeah.
Absolutely.
So, after a while, after a
couple years, I just made sure
that they were two separate worlds.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
Keep it--
>> Gene Luen Yang: It really felt
like two separate identities.
>> Michael Cavna: You had to
have that different identity.
Yeah. Yeah.
Well, can you talk a
little bit about, you know,
you have depicted yourself in
comics at times and here what we see
on the screen, if we could go
to it, we just saw model sheet,
but could you talk about, you
know, what we're seeing here?
Just talk about the origin of this.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Sure.
This is a page from American
Born Chinese and in this scene,
the main character, Jin,
Chinese-American boy,
is thinking about his
classmate's curly hair.
And this eventually leads
to him getting a perm.
This is actually loosely based
off something that a friend
of mine in junior high did.
I had this friend who was Chinese.
He was fairly popular, he
was athletic, you know,
in seventh grade he had
a bunch of girlfriends.
And then when he came back
from eighth grade, we--
you know, I didn't
see him all summer.
When he came back from eighth
grade, he came back with a perm.
In general-- in general, perms
on Chinese people are a bad idea.
Just in general.
At least Chinese men.
And I remember because he
was like the most popular kid
in our little group,
nobody said anything,
but that always stuck
out to me in my head.
Like I didn't understand
why he would get a perm.
So, in the book, I play
with that a little bit.
You know? The perm for Jin is a way
of him expressing his
own insecurities.
I don't know if that's true
of my friend, like my actual,
actual friend, but that's the story
purpose it serves in the book.
>> Michael Cavna: When you were
creating American Born Chinese,
which, again, came out
about a decade ago,
I mean it's a masterwork.
Did you feel as though you were
creating a masterwork in the process
or were you just one perm at a time?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Well, first,
thank you for saying that.
When I was doing American
Born Chinese,
I was doing it as mini-comics.
I finished a chapter, I would
Xerox it, I'd staple it by hand,
I'd take it to local
conventions and sell it.
There was a comic book
store in Berkeley,
California that was
willing to sell Xerox comics
and I sold it through there.
So, like literally 16 people
read it, you know, in that form.
It's not a-- I mean I just--
what I wanted to do was I wanted
to impress my cartoonist friend.
I wanted like Derek Kirk
Kim to read the book
and go oh you did a pretty good job.
>> Michael Cavna: And did he?
>> Gene Luen Yang: He did.
>> Michael Cavna: OK, so you
impressed 16 friends at a time.
And can you talk about this?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
This is-- this is the--
this is Jin with the perm.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
Yeah. Look at that.
>> Gene Luen Yang: My friend
actually looked more ridiculous
than that.
It was-- I'm not skilled enough to
capture the actual ridiculousness
of what a Chinese man
looks like with a perm.
>> Michael Cavna: OK.
And what about this?
>> Gene Luen Yang: This is a
page from Boxers and Saints,
which up until this point has been
my most time consuming project.
It's a two-volume graphic novel
all about the Boxer Rebellion,
which is a war that was fought
on Chinese soil in the year 1900.
I have two volumes because I
personally could not decide
who the good guys were.
So, in one book the
Boxers are the good guys.
They're these Chinese
teenagers who believed
that they could call the
Chinese gods down from the skies
and these gods would
give them super powers
so they could fight
off the foreigners
and in the other book it
is the Chinese Christians
who are the good guys who were
the enemies of the boxers.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
Well, there's two parts of that
I want to take and, first of all,
did you realize-- I mean
it's like reading two epics.
You get two epics for
the price of one.
Did you realize what
you were getting
into when you couldn't
decide which side to take
that you-- it would be this tome?
>> Gene Luen Yang: In my
original-- in my original proposal,
I had proposed one book that
would be about 200 pages
and I just kept writing
and writing and writing
and it just got-- it
got out of hand.
It got--
>> Michael Cavna: It's
over 500, approaching 600?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah,
it's over 500 pages.
Yeah. It just got out of hand.
>> Michael Cavna: So, the
boxer side, to me, had--
you can't get the Marvel
geek out of you.
I mean when they're
calling the gods,
it also plays like
fantastic superheroes to me.
Was that intentional?
>> Gene Luen Yang: I mean
it was Chinese Shazam.
Like I would read about this
history about these kids, you know,
getting possessed by these old,
old Chinese legendary heroes
and it really felt like I
was reading about Shazam.
You know? That's what it was like.
And I don't know if that's--
I mean that's probably the
superhero geek in me as well.
>> Michael Cavna: Absolutely.
>> Gene Luen Yang: I
really-- as I was researching,
I saw a lot of parallels
between Chinese opera
and American superheroes and
that's why I have Chinese opera
in this scene.
So, the way these kids would
find out about these old,
legendary Chinese heroes
was through opera.
They didn't have comic books.
They didn't have cartoons.
They didn't have TV shows.
They had these traveling
acting troops that would go
from one village to the other,
performing traditional
Chinese opera.
>> Michael Cavna: Absolutely.
>> Gene Luen Yang: And they
were colorful, they were full
of superpowers, and they
were basically inspired
by their pop culture, these
operas, the same way we are.
And in some ways this
possession, you know,
this Chinese Shazam dynamic
really felt like cosplay to me.
It felt like-- you know?
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Like if-- if--
if they weren't in
such dire situations,
if their country was not literally
falling apart all around them,
they would still have this impulse
to become their heroes, right?
The same way we do.
>> Michael Cavna: But that's amazing
to even attempt, if
you think about it.
We're going to-- you're going
to take the Boxer Rebellion,
something that serious,
but let's work Shazam
and let's work cosplay into that.
I mean that's amazing.
And I will say on the saints' side,
you know, you deal with Christianity
and it feels like you're calling
upon your own religious upbringing
in some way.
You can't do that without--
I would think-- doing that.
Can you talk about that side of it?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Sure.
I-- I grew up-- I grew up in
a Chinese Catholic community
that met right outside of San
Francisco and then I think
like most adults who
consider themselves a part
of a faith tradition, I
did go through a period
of really serious doubt and
then eventually I came back.
I came back to the faith tradition
of my childhood, but
in a different way.
Definitely in a different way.
So, the saints' side was really
inspired by one of my relatives.
I have a relative who converted
to Catholicism as an adult
and when she was a
kid-- when she was born,
she was born under a bad luck day
on the traditional Chinese calendar
and because she was born on
this day she had a grandfather
that hated her.
She had a little sister that
was born on a good luck day
and whenever the grandfather
had treats, she would--
like the little sister would get
the treats, but she would not.
As an adult, she converts
to Catholicism.
She converts to this
faith of another culture
and she never connects
these two things together,
but it seemed to me so obvious.
You know? She was-- she
couldn't find a place for herself
in the beliefs of her family,
so she looked for the
beliefs of this other culture.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
It's so powerful.
It's such a multilayered work.
If you haven't read Boxers and
Saints, I highly recommend it.
And here we're talking
about transformation, right?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
This is the Shazam moment.
This is the-- the possessing god is
actually the first emperor of China.
He's the guy who made China
into a single unified country.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
And you're mixing the big splash
panels with the smaller panels.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
And this is actually a
ritual that the Boxers did
that I found in my research.
They would bow a certain--
like they believed they had
to perform this ritual in order
to call the Chinese gods down,
so they would bow a certain
way, they would eat ashes,
they would like-- they
would write these charms
and eat the ashes of the charms.
They would breathe-- they
would control their breathing
in a certain way and when this
happened the gods would come down
and take over their bodies.
>> Michael Cavna: And we'd
get something like this.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
Yeah. And that's another
transformation.
>> Michael Cavna: So, not
just superheroes, you were--
I mean you must have really
studied opera visuals and really--
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah, I got a
bunch of books about Chinese opera.
And, like I said, looking at it from
the lens of somebody who grew up on
like superhero comics, it all looked
like it was using the same language.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
Yeah. On some level,
I'm sure it was.
Yeah. And then you got the Avengers.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah, yeah.
That's exactly what it is.
The Avengers.
>> Michael Cavna: There is a
super team, historically set.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah and Boxers
and Saints is definitely
my bloodiest book.
By far. Like, in the
beginning, if you look at--
if you look at the
boxers' book especially--
in the beginning, I tried to keep
all of the violence off panel.
You know, you just see
splashes of blood flying.
And then by the end
I was just like--
>> Michael Cavna: Which
is what you do--
and Secret Coders gets
pretty bloody, right?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah,
in the later volumes.
Lots of decapitations.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
So, can you talk about this work?
>> Gene Luen Yang: This is
from a book called Level Up,
which I did with a friend
of mine named Thien Pham.
He's one of my best friends, but
every now and again I do hate him.
And level up is actually about a
young man who loves video games,
but one night he's visited by these
angels and these angels tell him
that it's his destiny
to go to medical school.
It is inspired by the
life of my brother.
I have a brother who is younger
than me, he's four years younger.
He is actually a medical doctor.
So, he is the Asian parental dream.
And when he was going
through med school,
he would tell me all these stories
about what he had to do, right?
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: And--
are any of you doctors?
Or you must know doctors, right?
Doctors look-- they
look so professional
in their little white suits,
those little white jackets,
but what they had to do to get
that doctor degree is gross.
It's disgusting.
So, my brother would call me up,
he'd tell me all these stories
about gross things that
he would have to do,
how he'd have to put his hands in
places that hands just don't belong.
It's just gross.
And every time he told me one of
these stories, I thought, man,
this would really work great in a
graphic novel, but the problem is
when I'm trying to
think through a story,
I want like a narrative thread.
I want some kind of underlying
dramatic spine that kind
of ties everything together and
what he was giving me was not that.
He was just giving me one
interesting thing after the other.
Oh, I had to collect my own fecal
matter to examine my own gut flora.
You know? Or oh, I had to
label hemisected human heads.
And then finally one day he calls
me up and he gives me that thread.
So, this is what he says.
He calls me up and
he says, you know,
I'm thinking about being
a gastroenterologist.
You all know what that is?
That's a doctor who specializes
in the digestive tract.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Like from
the beginning to the end.
My brother is an incredibly,
incredibly squeamish person.
When we were kids, I remember
we had these action figures
that were a certain color of
yellow and he gave them away.
Like I came home one
day and they were gone.
I was like what happened
to the action figures
and he said well they kind of
looked like barf and I couldn't deal
with it, so I gave them away.
That's how squeamish he is.
So, I said to him-- I said
out of all the people I know,
you would make the worst
gastroenterologist because you--
like you realize you are going to be
like elbow deep in
human fecal matter?
You're not going to be
able to deal with it.
And he said well, but the other
day I did this colonoscopy
and it was kind of like playing
video games up somebody's butt.
>> Michael Cavna: Oh man.
Oh.
>> Gene Luen Yang: And as
soon as he gave me that,
that was my narrative thread.
>> Michael Cavna: Wow.
Like Pac Man.
Everything takes on a different--
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
I mean it just-- I saw the
entire story unfold like--
>> Michael Cavna: I just give you
credit you didn't call it GI Joe
meets GI tract.
That would have been
[inaudible] than that,
but no, but it's beautiful.
Even the way you do it
in blue monochromatic--
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah, well
I can't take credit for that.
That was from-- that was Thien Pham.
He did the art on that one.
>> Michael Cavna: It's wonderful.
Well, here we have-- you spent
a year following a high school
basketball team.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah, a season.
>> Michael Cavna: A season.
I'm sorry.
A season. What-- as you've said,
you know nothing or knew nothing
about basketball, so this wasn't
like a passion project sport-wise.
What compelled you to say
I want to follow a team,
a high school team, for a season?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Well,
basketball was always a point
of pain for me when I was a kid.
Mostly because I sucked at it.
You know? And then I was
relatively tall for an Asian,
so within Asian communities at
least, people would look at me
and expect me to be good at it
and then as soon as they saw me
on the court they were like oh.
I was a train wreck.
I was a train wreck on the court.
So, I never liked basketball.
That just started to
change fairly recently.
My son had something to do with it.
He started getting
interested in basketball,
he plays for a school team now.
Jeremy Lin had something
to do with it.
And then I started paying
attention to basketball stories.
Books had something to do with it
because I started reading basketball
books and what I realized was
that basketball specifically
as a sport has all sorts
of overlap with culture, you know?
There is a reason why certain
cultures gravitate towards
basketball because--
like for instance--
for instance, in early
immigrant Catholic communities,
basketball was huge and basketball--
like Catholic universities
still dominate basketball.
If you look at the NCAA tournament,
Catholic universities are
usually overrepresented.
Right? And it's because--
because of Catholic immigrants
because Catholic immigrants,
when they came to this country,
they could not afford
to maintain fields.
Maintaining a grass
field was too expensive,
so they immediately just put
all of their athletic resources
into this sport that only needed two
hoops, a ball, and some concrete.
Right? And then in China as well.
China actually learned how to
play basketball about a year
after it was invented because
of these YMCA missionaries.
And they immediately
latched on to the sport.
They latched on because these YMCA
missionaries told them, you know,
the health of your country is
tied to the health of your bodies.
So, they look at these missionaries,
these missionaries grew up,
you know, eating a western diet.
They were usually like
six inches taller
than the average Chinese
person at the time
and then their country was
falling apart all around them.
This was right after
the dynasty fell apart
and they're like that makes sense.
So, they started playing basketball.
And basketball was
one of the few things
that Chairman Mao did not
excise out of his country.
The few western elements that
Chairman Mao did not excise
out of the country when the
communists came into power.
So-- so to this day the Chinese
are fascinated with basketball.
It's like the second-largest--
it's the fasting growing
sport in the country, right?
And it all dates back
to that original idea.
Strong bodies lead
to a strong country.
So, you know, I started
reading about basketball.
It became really fascinating to me
and then I discovered
this amazing story
that was happening
right on my campus.
I went and talked to the
coach of the varsity team.
His name is Lou Ritchie.
That's him right there.
That's my drawing of him right
there in the lower corner.
And he told me that he
was an alum of O'Dowd.
He had also gone to the same
school where we were both teaching
and when he was a junior
he had gone with his team,
the varsity men's basketball team,
to the California State
Championship.
They were down by one
with seven seconds left.
He gets the ball in his
hand, he puts it up,
it goes through the
hoop, they're up by one,
the buzzer sounds,
everybody freaks out.
Everyone's celebrating and then
the refs invalidate that last shot.
>> Michael Cavna: Oh, man!
>> Gene Luen Yang: They
invalidate it because one
of his teammates had his hand
over the rim, so it was--
>> Michael Cavna: Like
a goal tending.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah,
it was offensive violation,
but Lou plays this tape back
for me over and over again.
He goes, look, do you think
his hand was over the rim
and I got to admit, hard to tell.
So, Lou goes-- Lou goes on, he plays
for UCLA, he plays for Clemson,
he gets a hamstring
injury, it's over,
and then he comes back
to O'Dowd as a coach.
And, as a coach, he leads six teams
to the California State Championship
and he loses all six times.
>> Michael Cavna: Not on a
goal tend each time, though?
OK.
>> Gene Luen Yang: No, not
on a goal tend each time,
but he never redeems himself.
You know what I mean?
He never redeems himself.
So, supposedly the 2014-2015
season was his best chance
at finally winning.
>> Michael Cavna: And we're
not going to say what happened.
>> Gene Luen Yang: So, I
mean-- it's over, right?
I can tell you what happened.
>> Michael Cavna: I mean the book
isn't out, so it's up to you.
It's up to you and
your publisher, right?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Well,
I'll tell you this.
They made it to the
State Championship
and it was an amazing game.
It was the most amazing basketball
game I have ever, ever seen.
It was crazy.
Yeah, afterwards I-- Thien,
who I did Level Up with,
he's also a cartoonist,
after that game was over,
he calls me up and
he goes I hate you.
You just got the-- you just
got the best ending ever.
I hate you so much.
>> Michael Cavna: So, you can guess.
So, but to me in terms of
diversity and cultural richness,
you've got two, you know,
you and I talked about this,
there's sort of two distinct levels.
One thing-- we can get
into the team in a moment,
but you talk about school.
You have teachers.
You said within the
cafeteria groups sat--
we think sometimes only kids sit
according to whether you're a nerd
or drama club or whatever,
but you said there was among
the teachers sort of divisions.
Can you talk about that?
>> Gene Luen Yang: I mean there
were a few teachers at that school
that would drift from
group to group,
just like there are a few
kids that do that, right?
But a lot of us, most of us,
would sit with our own kind.
So, all the nerdy teachers
would sit together,
all the drama teachers
would sit together.
All the PE teachers
So, like, me and Lou-- Lou
was not the kind of guy
that I would normally
be friends with.
You know? He's a jock.
He walks around with a
swagger that I just don't have
that I find really intimidating.
But, as I got to talking
to him, I realized that he
and I just have a lot in common.
He also loves books.
He also loves statistics
and numbers.
He's like a nerd at heart.
He's a nerd who knows
how to play basketball.
That's all it is.
Right? And I think that's
going to be something I talk
about in the book as well,
how he and I became friends.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
Well, also you found out
this richness about the team.
You found out this richness
about the-- like there was one--
was there one player who
actually-- was he wearing headgear?
Was he wearing, you
know, religiously?
Can you--
>> Gene Luen Yang: He wasn't--
no, he wasn't wearing headgear.
So, there was this one Sikh player
and he was the only Sikh
player in the league.
He did not observe
kesh, so he didn't--
he didn't wear the traditional--
the traditional head coverings.
But, when I followed team,
I realized that he just--
he just took a lot of crap.
You know? People would call him
a terrorist from the stands.
People would call him an Arab.
People would call him Osama been
hoopin', which he laughed at.
He thought it was funny, but
it also was really irritating
and what I realized was that, you
know, if you look at the history
of basketball, basketball has
always been this weird pot
of racial tensions.
You know, early on there were a lot
of ethnic teams, they played it up.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah, it was
the immigrant experience they grew
up in.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yes.
Yeah, they played up
their ethnicities.
There was a Chinese team that
played early on in the history
of basketball and they would--
they would speak in Cantonese even
though they all spoke English way
better than they spoke Cantonese.
The Harlem Globetrotters
started off as a gimmick team
and eventually they
transcended that,
but they started off
as a gimmick team.
So, that racial animosity, I think
when we look at it as modern people,
we look at the modern basketball
court, we think that's gone.
We're over it.
We're past it.
Because nobody goes and insults
each other explicitly, right?
Except for this one Sikh kid.
Like most people who go
and watch basketball,
they know not to insult any of
the African-American players,
so they take all that tension and
they direct it at this one Sikh kid
and it was-- it was
just a little bit--
it was a little bit
shocking for me to see.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
And how did he deal with it?
I mean, you know--
>> Gene Luen Yang: He-- yeah,
that's something that I talk
about in the book, but he--
eventually it just-- he just--
he just learned that he had to let
it be like water off a duck's back.
You know? And I don't even know if--
I mean I don't think
that's fair to him.
I don't think that's the best
way for him to deal with it,
but that was the way
that he kept playing.
He-- what he wanted was he
wanted his game to speak for him.
You know?
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
You've always written on many
layers and written obviously things
and family friends
can all feed that in,
but before you were
always writing fiction.
You have freedom.
Here, nonfiction.
You're a reporter.
You're a journalist and you're in
the locker room and sometimes it's--
sometimes you're disappearing in the
locker room and sometimes, you know,
it's always are you affecting
the story that you're covering
when you're present, right?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Exactly.
>> Michael Cavna: So, there's
a host of challenges you face
by writing a nonfiction narrative.
How is that going?
>> Gene Luen Yang: It's--
it's been really hard.
I got to say it's been really hard
because-- because it's a cartoon,
there's automatically a level
of fiction there, right?
The way I'm drawing them is not the
way they actually physically look
and even the action I have to both
simplify and exaggerate in order
for it to work on the comics page.
So, what I try to do is I try
to make sure all the
words are accurate,
but then the pictures
have to lie a little bit.
You know? In order for it
to work as a graphic novel.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
So, we talked about
O'Dowd, did you--
being in schools for a couple
decades, did you see a difference
in how graphic novels were received?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yes.
Absolutely.
When I got on that campus, no
teachers were using graphic novels
in the classroom, even me.
And now I can at least count
half a dozen, if not more.
>> Michael Cavna: Was it
ignorance, bias, and prejudice?
What-- a mix of all that?
>> Gene Luen Yang: I think it
was just a lack of awareness.
You know? Actually,
I take that back.
When I got on campus, there was
one class that used a graphic novel
and it was a holocaust
history class that used Maus.
But, at that point, I
think when people thought
of literary graphic novels,
they only thought of Maus
and now they think of
Persepolis, they think of Smile.
You know? It's been amazing.
>> Michael Cavna: And they--
you make sure they think of
Boxers and Saints all the time.
Part of that too is-- one thing you
said to me several years ago was
that librarians get it sooner
because they're on the front lines.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yes.
>> Michael Cavna: You know,
teachers, you're in your classroom,
you can have your lesson plan,
but teachers are every
day getting the requests.
Can you-- you saw a
shift there, too?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
Absolutely.
I mean librarians have always
been on the front lines.
Right? Librarians realize
that the presence
of graphic novels increases
overall circulation by 30%.
That's something that
most librarians have seen,
have firsthand experience of.
And it just takes the rest of us
educators a little bit more time.
>> Michael Cavna: Another thing
where we're seeing a profound change
is what I would call gender equity
and geek culture.
Some studies, depending on
how you define geek culture,
actually have said roughly 50-50%
boys and girls, men and women.
I know when I-- when I
first as a teenager went
to San Diego Comic-Con, I
talked to Stan Sakai about this.
He would bring his family and
he said often in a room my wife,
my daughter might be the
only women anywhere near--
it was so male dominated and there
are reasons for that, but the--
web culture has changed things,
but discovering the appeal
of certain books to girls,
YA classrooms, we-- that--
I believe that's another area where
we're seeing a revolution, right?
>> Gene Luen Yang: We are.
We are.
>> Michael Cavna: It feels-- I have
a daughter and it feels massive.
Can you talk about that?
>> Gene Luen Yang:
It's hugely massive.
I think it's hugely massive, right?
I think it's taken this long
for publishers to realize
that young girls love comics.
You know? It took-- like
Raina had a really hard time--
>> Michael Cavna: Raina Telgemeier.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Had a
really hard time selling Smile
and now everybody-- every publisher
is trying to get their own Smile.
I think it's-- I think
it's wonderful.
I think it's amazing.
I think it's such a hopeful time.
>> Michael Cavna: It really is.
I mean I've talked with Scott
McCloud this [inaudible],
he thinks within a decade women
are going to dominate comics.
He thinks the pendulum
is going to swing.
All I will know is like the
first time my daughter--
Raina Telgemeier was unknown
and she walked up to the booth
and she said I like
this and Raina smiled
because there was something there.
And I listened--
>> Gene Luen Yang:
And then millions of--
>> Michael Cavna: Millions
topping the best seller list.
Yeah. Absolutely.
>> Gene Luen Yang: It's an
incredibly hopeful time to be--
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
So, as you travel around,
you're seeing--
>> Gene Luen Yang:
Oh, we did get the--
>> Michael Cavna: Did we get it?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah, we did.
>> Michael Cavna: Do we
have time for any questions
or do we have-- couple questions?
Anyone? Bueller?
Bueller? Yes.
>> Hi. I work for a company that
makes water filters with writing
on them for water sanitation
education
and it's always a challenge to
make things culturally appropriate
and to do your due diligence
and to make things fit.
How do you go about
researching cultures
where you can't necessarily
go-- you have to rely on forums
or other people, do you-- do
you have to immerse yourself?
What is your practice?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
It's hard.
Right now I'm writing
the new Superman book.
It's set in Shanghai.
I've never lived in Shanghai
before; I've only visited twice.
What I've been doing is
I've been reading a lot.
I read-- I read books about
what modern China is like.
I read blogs about people--
by people who live there,
and I've also gotten-- I've also
been lucky enough to get in touch
with people who actually
live in Shanghai,
so I can email them
questions and stuff.
Like what music are you guys
listening to, that sort of thing.
But it's always that--
I think it's always hard
to do your due diligence, but I'm
thankful that you're doing it.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
Absolutely.
And one thing you said in your talk
in 2014 was do the
homework, find people, vet it.
Find people who really
know it and go through it.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Find
insiders, I think that's--
you just can't-- you
can't replace that.
>> Michael Cavna: Yeah.
Absolutely.
Yes. Right here.
>> Thank you.
Really enjoy your talk.
I'm proud that I share some
part of your Asian parts and,
as you can tell, I have two boys.
And so I have a question,
very practical.
This is a parenting-- you
have-- your parents have this--
I guess this extremely
successful parenting model for you
and your brother, so
I want to do both.
Please come and-- what
your parents--
the tips, three or
five, and I can emulate.
>> Gene Luen Yang: My parents?
My parents-- my parents-- well, OK.
So, my dad was very much
a typical immigrant dad.
He gave me three choices in life:
doctor, lawyer, or engineer.
And I kind of did one, right?
I majored in computer
science and I kind of did it.
And when I was a kid especially,
I just ended up fighting
with him a lot.
I wanted to do cartoons.
He wanted me to do
something more practical.
As an adult, I look
back and I see that--
I think my parents had a
point, especially my dad.
Health insurance is
an important thing.
And now I really believe
that-- I believe in a balance.
I believe in the balance of pursuing
your dreams while respecting the
wisdom of your parents.
While getting health insurance.
>> Michael Cavna: So, if
some of your kids only want
to be comics creators and never want
to do anything else,
you're good with that?
>> Gene Luen Yang: No.
Well, what I would tell them-- what
I would tell them is this-- is--
is in order for-- I--
in order for you--
so, not every cartoonist agrees
with me and there are plenty
of successful cartoonists that
use a different model, right?
But what-- but the model that
I felt like I follow was this.
In order for you to protect--
perfect your craft--
not even perfect it.
In order for you to
work on your craft,
it's going to take you
10 years of losing money.
At least 10 years of losing money.
How are you going to feed
yourself those 10 years?
If you're planning on
feeding yourself with art,
you're going to end up drawing
things that you do not want to draw.
That is not going to help
you develop as an artist.
So, you need to find some other way
of feeding yourself while
you work on that art.
>> Michael Cavna: Sure.
And what if your child says
I'm going to feed myself
on the MacArthur Genius Grant?
[ Laughter ]
We have time for one-- one?
>> So, I originally
had a ton of questions
about Avatar: The Last Airbender.
Huge fan.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Me too.
>> But, I'm also a
graphic novel artist.
I actually graduated from
Carnegie Mellon for music major
and then I got into comics later.
So, I was wondering, for you, what
was like your step one in terms
of like getting your work out there
so people know it exists
and then like--
>> Gene Luen Yang: My step
one was printing it out.
Was taking it to Xerox.
Eventually I moved
to offset printing,
which was a little
bit more expensive,
and then just handing out.
Like selling it by hand at shows.
That was my step one.
Nowadays, if I were to do it
over again, I would still do
that because I love print, I
love holding something physical
in my hand, but I would
also try to use the web.
For sure. I think networking
was hugely important to me.
I met some cartoonists who
were at about the same place
in their careers, really,
really early on
and we ended up pushing each other.
As soon as one of us met an
editor, all of us would meet
that same editor because
we would get introduced
and that was incredibly important.
>> Thanks.
>> Michael Cavna: Well said.
OK. Well, your wife just texted me.
She says, OK, you are a genius.
So, thank you.
You're there.
Thank you.
Please give a big round of
applause to Gene Luen Yang.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Thank you.
Thank you all for staying.
Wonderful to talk to you all.
Thank you.
>> Michael Cavna: All right.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.